well yesterday we started the show with
this disastrous news out of Italy in
which a far-right nationalist group with
individuals within it like Georgia
Maloney who have neo-fascist roots and
origins in their sort of political lives
are coming to power in Italy and we also
talked a little more broadly about the
origins and the catalysts for this
rightward shift in Italy it shouldn't
surprise us that in the 24 hours
following the news of what's taking
place in Italy American right Wingers
who of course don't claim to be fascists
or neo-fascists or anything of the sort
have rallied behind Georgia Maloney in
some cases without even actually knowing
what her name is Marjorie Taylor green
referring to her as George Joe maybe she
thinks it's a man I don't really know
but we'll get to that in a moment and
saying that this is a great thing that
there is the rise of the right in Europe
which is not altogether wrong in fact we
talked about that yesterday but also
pretending as though Georgia Maloney and
her party are just kind of mainstream
individuals rather than the extreme
rightists that they are so let's take a
look at a couple of Clips first here is
Charlie Kirk on the Charlie Kirk show
saying this isn't fascism Georgia
Maloney and her ideology this is middle
of the road common sense
um
take a listen
here of course on the American Media is
Georgia Maloney being called a fascist
on MSNBC you know they're all for
democracy until somebody who they don't
like wins and then they call well
there's there's two different things
here right you can be a fascist who won
through Democratic means now she's not
literally a fascist but she was a member
when she was younger of the youth front
that's a neo-fascist it's the youth wing
of a neo-fascist political party called
the Italian social movement it's it's
not a question of opinion it's what it
is that person Mussolini play Cut 35.
the the victory of a party that has its
roots in Italian fascism yeah plain and
simple uh the the brothers of Italy it's
called Georgia Maloney's party uh is
concerning to everybody uh it
accompanies as you said this move in
Europe who could think that in Sweden uh
a party with right-wing neo-fascist
Roots would now be dominant in in
Parliament
it's sweeping all across Europe and they
can't figure out why
it's not fascist it's common sense it's
normal it's middle of the road
it's about things
that are
eternally important
not about gender Theory post-modernist
constructs
squashing the imperialist colonialist
history no no this is about things that
transcend all of that and this is a
perfect example of exactly how these
parties become popular we talked about
this yesterday we we talked about
exactly this this is what they do this
is the type of stuff that they say oh
these are about the real issues you've
got to be afraid of immigrants from
other countries we've got to stop the
gender stuff by saying that this is
normal he is proving exactly the point
we made yesterday
the American political scene is going
through the exact same thing now and we
now if you see
the globalists ah the globalists
the globalists there it is the uniparty
they have to do everything they possibly
can
to try and
thwart this movement now we're going to
get back to that in a moment but it was
not just Charlie Kirk Marjorie Taylor
green tweeting congratulations to
Giorgio Maloney and to the people of
Italy of course just another one of
Marjorie Taylor Green's typos as usual
and radical and repugnant Republican
congresswoman Lauren bobert
tweeted quote this month Sweden voted
for a right-wing government now Italy
voted for a strong right-wing government
she has to acknowledge that in Italy
it's even further right but she can't
use the term neo-fascist the entire
world is beginning to understand that
the woke left does nothing but destroy
November 8 is coming soon and the USA
will fix our house and Senate Let
Freedom Reign this is a hard right
ideology that dabbles into neo-fascism
now in the last 24 hours there have been
many
enlightened centrists and others who
have come out of the woodwork and said
it's not really fascism Georgia Maloney
it's it's the brothers of Italy it's not
really fascism
no but it has its origins in fascism
Maloney joined the youth front which is
the youth wing of the neo-fascist
political party the Italian social
movement MSI in 1992.
they've taken these extreme nationalist
positions hard line against immigration
put out the Italian Navy to patrol the
water and block migrants from arriving
by sea Vox has written that Maloney's
Victory will roll back minority rights
including the rights of women lgbtq
people and migrants it's the typical
hard right package the brothers of Italy
use the Insignia and the slogan God
country family which is an echo to its
fascist predecessors she's against
abortion she's against same-sex marriage
she's against same-sex parenting she's
against multiculturalism in May of 2020
she praised Giorgio almirante who's the
co-founder of the Italian social
movement which is that group that uh
neo-fascist group I told you about
almirando was a Nazi collaborator and
editor-in-chief of an anti-semitic and
racist magazine which published
something called the manifesto of race
there's a lot of this stuff
melonious praised the Italian dictator
Mussolini as a quote good politician the
best of the last 50 years that was in a
French newscast in 1996. so this stuff
is not just being made up out of thin
air this is the reality and what's
happening is a sort of rewriting of
History some people don't really know
that much about Italian fascism others
are easily convinced that this is
nothing to do with it but the roots of
this movement are Italian fascism that's
the reality and so certainly you can
make the case she is not a fascist per
se and I'm with you but this is a
hard-right group with its origins in
terms of the individuals that make it up
in neo-fascism and even worse and it
shouldn't shock us even for a second
that the right Wingers are jumping to
defend it because they've openly openly
um
romanticized these types of movements
during the Trump era we have an
incredible bit of news the White House
called a trump rioter on January 6th
uh oh why would that be the case well
let's see if we can figure this out but
this is blowing the lid off of yet
another part of the Trump Riot
investigation there's a CNN article that
summarizes this quite well listen to
this on January 6th at 4 34 PM a cell
phone registered to a capital right of
rioter who stormed the capital got a
phone call from a White House landline
okay CNN has obtained the records other
news outlets have looked at the records
this happened okay White House calls
calls a trump rioter on January 6. the
call lasts nine seconds hmm who placed
the call from the White House well we
don't know right now because the White
House has landlines and many people work
at the White House so we don't know
could have been anybody who works at the
White House okay
according to the records the call came
from a 202 number which is the publicly
available number for the White House
doesn't show a specific extension so we
don't know who's whose phone it came
from the call was placed in the late
afternoon right after Trump did the
video message saying to the rioters we
love you but go home
it's unclear CNN writes what if any
connection exists between the White
House and the rioter including whether
the call was made by mistake and whether
the call went to voicemail
mistake
that'd be quite a coincidental wrong
number quite a coincidental wrong number
um what else do we know about it well we
know who the call was made to
the cell phone belonged to a 26 year old
Trump supporter from Brooklyn New York
named Anton lennick
who traveled to DC the night before with
two friends according to multiple
sources familiar with the investigation
the three men attended the stop the
steel rally on the ellipse and then with
hundreds of others entered and illegally
demonstrated inside the capital
they were charged they pleaded guilty in
April and they were sentenced
um earlier this month
all three declined to comment to CNN
according to multiple sources Lennox
says he doesn't remember getting that
nine second call from the White House
and says he doesn't know anyone who
worked in the Trump White House
the phone call wasn't mentioned in
Lennox sentencing or in any court
documents and a spokesman for the U.S
attorney's Office in D.C has declined to
comment
so what exactly does this mean and there
are a number of questions here number
one how do you not remember a phone call
from the White House did you didn't get
the call or you got it but you don't
remember what was said or they left you
a voicemail or what you have no memory
of it that's different than I never
received such a call
I have no memory of it that's really
weird
it's obviously very difficult to believe
that it's a random coincidence there's a
riot going on
Trump says to the rioters that he loves
them but it's time to go home
one of the rioters is at the Capitol
and the White House it's like a butt
dial someone just happens to
accidentally call the phone of the
writer doesn't really make sense so it
obviously leads to speculation could it
be well someone at the white house uh
was in touch with this rioter met to
call the rioter on their cell phone but
realized they were using the White House
line and so they quickly hung up is that
a possibility again we're left to
speculate because the official
explanation so far don't make absolutely
any sense uh this particular writer
lunick was seen in the background of an
individual named baked Alaska's live
stream from Jeff merkley's office on
January 6th they'd broken into Jeff
merkley's office lanik you can see in
the background of a baked Alaska live
stream is it possible someone at the
White House was watching the Stream
sawlonic was like oh that's the guy
we've been in touch with or I know that
guy or something the other speculation
is lunick agreed to cooperate to some
degree for a lighter sentence is that
related to why there seems to be no
comment from anybody and not much of a
desire seemingly to get to the bottom of
who it is from the White House that
called Lennox only questions right now
but the fact that someone from the White
House called this guy
on the day of the riots raises all new
sets of questions about the connections
between the Trump White House and the
rioters not generally right of course
you can say well generally they were
like we'll make a speech and we'll say
let's walk down to Pennsylvania walk
down Pennsylvania Avenue and some of
these people are going to follow okay
fine we knew that this is about the
specific connection between an
individual at the White House and this
particular writer on that exact day
will we ever know what happened yeah I
think we actually will I think it's
likely that we will get to the bottom of
this multiple news agencies working on
it but it doesn't look good what do you
believe is the explanation for this
phone call let me know you can find me
on Twitter at dpacman
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the David Pacman show is of course an
audience supported program we do an
extra show every day for our members
it's called the bonus show we cover more
stories I'm joined by producer Pat every
single weekday and you can sign up
easily for the member show uh and the
bonus show both of them we do a member
show as well which is a commercial free
version of The Daily Show available
hours earlier than we publicly released
the show get all of it and more by
signing up at joinpakman.com I believe
the normal membership prices are very
very affordable however we also offer
coupon codes no means testing just if
you want the discount take the discount
you can use the coupon code indite to
get yourself a tidy little discount at
joinpakman.com you know yesterday we had
clips from this Texas Tribune event in
which California governor Gavin Newsom
was striking the exact right tone and
moral Clarity when it comes to
Republican Governor Ron desantis's
Martha's Vineyard immigrant stunt well
Gavin Newsom correctly pointing out this
is disgusting this is using people this
is bullying and I'm against this I'm
against this and I believe that he did a
great job of using the right language
and tone that Democrats need to use
let's not shy away from the fact that
the left does have the moral High Ground
on most issues
um when compared to these completely
amoral right-wingers well I have another
clip from that very same event and it's
of Transportation secretary Pete Buda
judge and again I've mentioned yesterday
I mentioned there are certain people
right now in the Democratic Party
that know how to talk about these issues
Gavin Newsom is one of them I've talked
about Katie Porter to some degree we've
talked about Stacy Abrams and Jamie
Raskin Pete boot Edge is also one of
those folks and here is Pete talking
about the Ron DeSantis stunt we need
more Democrats talking about issues in
this way take a look at this
don't have a solution right
where have easily Governor DeSantis was
in Congress where was he when they were
debating immigration reforms
what have any of these people done to be
part of the solution
so you know I get if you're after
attention
it's one thing to
call attention to
a problem
when you have a course of action as some
of the folks here speaking up about an
issue exercising their first amendment
rights have not or in elected office
it's another to just call attention to a
problem because the problem
is actually more useful to you than the
solution and that helps you call
attention to yourself correct
and
that's what's going on and the problem
of course it's one thing if that was
just people being obnoxious but human
beings are being impacted by that you
flee a communist regime in Venezuela you
come here
and then somebody tricks you somebody
using Florida taxpayer money for some
reason tricks you into going from Texas
to Massachusetts it's it's it's not just
ineffectual it is hurting people
in order to get attention
it is morally depraved what was done in
other words we need more Democrats
talking about issues in this way what
Gavin Newsom and mayor Pete Secretary of
Transportation he'll always be mayor
Pete to some degree what Newsom and
mayor Pete capture here is the essence
of how bad faith these Republicans are
I joke around about you know this guy
has upper management written all over
him there is some sense that Pete
butterjudge is not going to Peak at
Secretary of Transportation because he
is really good at this and unfortunately
we still have a situation where people
judge him for who he loves the fact that
he's married to a guy
I believe that that is going to be a
diminishing impediment for mayor Pete
over time I don't know how soon and I
don't know how quickly but what's
interesting is I actually have some sort
of Center center right I have some sort
of like socially liberal but typically
Republican voting friends for fiscal
reasons who you know they like Mitt
Romney for example they they kind of
like McCain
uh who like Pete not because they agree
or disagree so much with his social
views or his economic views but because
they feel that he strikes the right tone
and brings the right energy and is of an
interesting generation to be in a
position of power and so I actually
believe that particularly as quite
frankly overt homophobia hopefully
continues to diminish I think Pete Buda
judge has a real shot at uh higher
office than where he is now which is
Secretary of Transportation doing a
really good job there and I'm glad to
see more Democrats actually talking
about issues in this way it's necessary
we have the moral High ground there's no
reason to lose the rhetoric game it's
just we have to know how to talk about
the issues and some of these guys and
gals absolutely do hey you're gonna love
this an oan host brutally attacks me
tags the wrong David packman on
Instagram tagging a scam account
misspells my name and is generally
totally triggered here's the back story
of this few weeks ago I did a story
about oan host Allison Steinberg Allison
Steinberg had a conspiracy theory about
her nest thermostat I guess she rents an
apartment she moved into the apartment
there was a nest thermostat which like
every Nest Thermostat knows when you
walk by she calls it it's tracking her
in her home and she presented all sorts
of unproven conspiracy theories I did a
segment on it okay so that that was the
the video that I did we just showed you
a screenshot of it so Allison Steinberg
is furious with me and she now has done
a segment on oan imagine that this is
Trump's darling o-an attacking me you'll
notice my name isn't even spelled
correctly on the entire thing let's get
into it and what's sad is she's so
confused about these thermostats she
doesn't understand how they work take a
look at this I think you're gonna like
this as a nest thermostat installed
which I didn't really think much of
until I noticed it just started
adjusting the temperature when I wasn't
home now that's a feature you can turn
on and off okay I've had Nest
thermostats for a year there there's a
learning option where you go hey pay
attention to my activity and whether I'm
home which it Knows by whether you walk
by in front of the thermostat
and adjust
for maximum efficiency lower the
temperature or allow it to go up
depending on whether it's winter or
summer this is just a feature you can
turn it on and off
what I realized this device has the
ability to actually sense your
whereabouts it immediately led me to
believe that this is yet another system
that will soon be required in probably
every new home that's built which I
personally find deeply disturbing now
it's just HomeSense that's what it's
called you you can tell it
sense when I'm home or not you can turn
it off it's no big deal
and it was then that I made this video
expressing my concerns over the
technology but instead of playing you my
video I'm just going to go ahead and
show you a video of my video that's
right David packman a soy infused
triggered leftist what I had to say
about you know what's funny is I don't
really eat soy I mean every once in a
while I have you know like mapo tofu but
I where is this soy thing coming from
Bart thermostats tracking you was super
it was Preposterous that he made a whole
video making fun of me for thinking that
globalists were tracking me
utterly pathetic attempt at an Alex
Jones impression yeah okay so then she
plays my entire clip which we're gonna
skip over because you already know my
clip I'm not gonna play her playing my
clip okay so and then now we get back to
her commentary and you just have to
listen to this stuff hey David we get it
you think I'm a crazy conspiracy
theorist tin foil hat wearing Alex Jones
worshiping weirdo yes which I actually
take is a massive compliment thank you
ever so much
she's just saying I actually am all of
those things before to tell you David
that not
when thousands of x
Colorado tried adjusting their
thermostats Tuesday they learned they
couldn't Denver 7 consumer investigator
Jacqueline Allen talked with some of
those customers Jacqueline they're upset
they had no control over the temp in
their own home that's right and you know
Excel is calling calling this a rare
Energy emergency and yes they took over
tens of thousands of smart thermostats
here in Colorado for the first time
there was nothing homeowners could do
about it well shucks now Allison
Steinberg is so clueless that she
doesn't understand
that's a voluntary Colorado rewards
program
it's it's not mandatory
do you understand what you're signing up
for okay in Colorado they had this
program where if you opt in with your
smart thermostat it's your choice
Freedom okay if you opt in to let them
asset your temperature during so-called
energy emergencies you get a hundred
dollar credit and 25 bucks a year
it's optional there's no there's no
subterfuge people chose to do that are
the people too dumb to understand what
they're even signing up for well that
may be the case but it's not really a
conspiracy what do you know looks like
conspiracy theorists win again now what
do you have to say for yourself David I
I just said it this is a program people
chose to participate in I think you owe
me an apology along with about 22 000
other people Rico tried to crank up the
AC I mean it was 90 out and it was right
During the period that's when he found
out he had no control of his thermostat
a message from Excel on his thermostat
saying temperature locked during an
energy emergency and our thermostat was
locked in at 78 or 79 turns out he's not
alone Excel confirms to contact number
seven 22
000 customers were locked out of their
smart thermostats for hours on Tuesday
because they opted into the program by
choice to get get a hundred bucks and
then 25 a year to me an emergency means
there is you know life limb or you know
some other danger out there some limb
massive wildfires he says you have no
idea locked thermostats came with that
and it's not what he signed up for
second it just doesn't sit right with us
to not be able to control our own it
quite literally is what he signed up for
thermostat in your house you see David
when I say globalists I'm not just
referring to the top one percent upper
echelons of society ah I'm also talking
about all of their minions who are too
dumbed down to figure out what's going
on and are complicit in aiding said
globalists and carrying out and ushering
in their agenda I guess that's me
and by agenda I mean creating a spy
State and a social credit system all to
keep you safe can you imagine we sell it
as convenience oh look how cool this is
you don't have to worry about
remembering to turn off your air anymore
save money on your outrageously high
energy bills do you think she's figured
out that these are just settings on her
nest and she can turn all of them off
first you have double cross and let your
smart thermostat shut off while you're
away the same people who are creating
the problem are selling you the solution
big Tech and private companies are
teaming up to put you in a high-tech
social credit score prison and it's
honestly not even really a conspiracy at
this point now that we have dictators
like Governor griesball telling us when
we can and can't use our AC and home
appliances and today so she cuts to
Gavin Newsom the funny thing is this has
nothing to do with just Democratic
Governors Texas is you know Texas has
this ercot system where they've decided
to isolate their electrical grid and so
there's storms in the winter and nobody
has power it's crazy what Texas has done
Texas's energy grid patriotic
independent their Energy company they
did the same thing okay they did the
exact same thing and we covered it at
the time Texas's largest energy
companies say they adjust some customers
thermostats due to grid conditions
consumers say they weren't aware they
opted into such a program it's the same
thing with the Republican Governor it's
user error the customers don't know what
the hell they're opting into and she
wants to pretend it's globalish
foreign
Newsom and Democrats it's just user
error and people who don't know what the
hell they're doing and tomorrow
afternoon after 4 P.M in particular 4
P.M please turn your thermostat up to 78
degrees or higher and avoid to the
extent possible using any really large
appliances now since we've determined
that Alex Jones is more often than not
pretty much always right remember she
made fun of me for saying that she's
just an Alex Jones wannabe and now this
is the third time in the video she says
Alex Jones is right about basically
everything let's go go ahead and take a
little trip back to 2004. all right so
then she goes to a report from Alex
Jones let's now get to the final part of
this which is Allison's advice to me
well there you have it folks I don't
know what more you need to see they
started cultivating this technology
decades ago and the creators are
literally telling you exactly what
they're doing but sure go ahead David
keep drinking your soy and getting your
poison shots and believing everything
the media tells you whatever you do
definitely don't question anything ever
I'm questioning this but if you do see
this video I would just like to make a
couple of very small requests one please
stop uploading my content so you can
monetize it I could say the same to you
I believe you owe me some cash now along
with your apology and two for the love
of God stop playing your pre-recorded
sound bites impersonating Alex Jones
because quite frankly they suck and you
sound nothing like him move if you're
gonna make fun of someone at least do a
decent job okay oh and last thing your
button up sweater vests have got to go I
don't have any button-up sweater vests I
I don't know what she's talking about
you're already affiliated with the party
who's in support of maps so I would hate
for people to think that you're one of
them just saying
so anyway there is Allison Steinberg and
by the way Maps is like minor attracted
persons it's like a code word for
pedophile which is uh it's sort of their
playbook just call anybody you disagree
with a pedophile so extraordinarily
interesting stuff and one other little
funny note in her post she tags an
account called David packman show fan
with no followers that she thinks is me
and she couldn't even I mean it's crazy
every detail is crazy she tagged a Spam
impersonation account of me when she
uploaded this video scary stuff we'll
have this clip on our Instagram at
davidpakman show
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show today we
are going to be speaking to another 2022
candidate and we will be speaking with
Republican Allison Hayden Allison Hayden
is running for congress in California's
14th District against Eric swalwell the
current Democratic congressman from
California's 15th congressional district
now running in the 14th due to
redistricting Allison it's great to have
you on I really appreciate your time
good morning hi so indulge me if if you
will because there are such diverse
views about this among Republican
candidates running I've been starting
with what may be a simple question and
if it is that's great and we can move on
who is currently the president of the
United States
Joe Biden okay and do you believe that
his presidency reflects the will of the
people as they voted in 2020.
uh I doubt it I I don't know I don't
know you don't know where you doubt it
uh I would say with so much controversy
around election Integrity which is
actually my first
um
I think mandate when I get in is really
to clean up our election processes that
there are two there are too many
questions it's really not for me to I'm
not on the inside of that so well you
did retweet a meme that says Trump won
so it seems something made you believe
that that you do know who actually won
right so you you tweeted a meme that
says Trump won what makes you think
Trump won well you know I live in
Northern California and so many people
even Democrats
told me they voted Trump so the numbers
didn't seem to reflect my experience
and so so because some Democrats told
you this is my you know yeah in my own
interactions with people I mean Trump
did get six million votes so certainly
you could have been talking to some of
those six million that's not really
evidence of fraud is it
no I'm not I I will say I went in and I
was an observer in the processing of
votes okay and there were big problems
with that like what and I even called
out uh I I witnessed uh
a vote being called for Newsom
that I could clearly see was not Newsom
on the ballot
okay but in terms of you tweet you
tweeted that Trump won you tweeted that
Trump won
what do you have to believe that okay
election Integrity yeah so I I think
there are questions with the vote okay
and we need for for everyone
you know that's That's the basis of our
constitution is the sovereignty of the
people Fair absolutely that should be
the first and foremost
um
you know
concern on every American
heart that that be assured I'm with you
100 I'm with you 100 now when I see the
numbers and I say you know there are so
many more Democrats in California than
Republicans that we know from voter
registration and Joe Biden won
California by five million votes
you tweeted that Trump won but it's
because a few Democrats you spoke to
said they voted for Trump that that
sounds weak a little bit doesn't it
Allison no well you know what when you
have a vote that is uh perhaps
um compromised so are the registrations
actually anything electronic we we need
to run through all the voter rolls
because there are you know we don't
really know what's real so so you think
even the voter registration is uh the
veracity of what is being touted as uh
you know representative of Republicans
Or democrats but let me just say from
the outset David that I am not a waving
a party banner I think that Americans
are hurting this is not the election
or the time in America to be caring
about political party membership I think
that I rejected the Republican Party
endorsement
I want to
represent Republican values that made
this country strong and those that's
what I care about so I want to clean up
the vote and voter rolls because that's
that is you know the voice of the people
is what represents this country's
freedoms and you know we have to get to
the bottom of that we do but I guess the
issue I'm having Allison and this is why
I'm so interested in talking to you is
if you want to be taken seriously on
that it seems as though some of the
things you're repeating on your Twitter
don't really make it so that someone
would take you seriously I'll give you
another example yesterday you retweeted
a meme indicating that 25
000 dead people voted in Michigan that's
been looked at the that that's just not
true why why would you retweet that if
you're so serious about this you know
Twitter for me is as much about raising
awareness and about uh people really
rethinking all of these things because
you know again I saw that
um actually today I just saw that the
Secretary of State Benson yeah had voted
to keep 26
000 dead people on on the voter rolls so
we have problems okay that's long and
short of it and Twitter I use
as education and to bring awareness and
to bring discussion we need to have
discourse about it and it ferrets out
more information you know when you throw
things into the Public Square I this
whole notion of discourse this is what
is lost in America and this is what made
us strong iron Allison I'm sorry I hate
to interrupt but you're going so off
track do you how many dead people do you
believe voted in Michigan
you know I again I'm not on the inside I
could not speak to that question so how
did you why were you comfortable
retweeting something for us to all look
at the voter rolls uh I don't know if
you've seen any of Dr Douglas Frank's
interview uh his actually he's been
going around the country showing us what
he discovered and he's done just on
Public Information
um watching and he has the voter rolls
for the last 20 years he's potentially
criminally in possession of voting
machines and is being investigated by
the FBI I don't know that that Douglas
Frank is the person I would look to on
this but in the end I'm not sure the FBI
is where I would look to for for
confidence either oh yeah are you a
supporter of law enforcement you know I
am definitely but you know what we have
I think what's been exposed in America
yeah is it's underbelly and we have many
problems across many institutions and
this is the hour to clean up America not
to shore up anything that has has uh
Fallen you know when you have humans
leading institutions you can expect that
there's going to you know eventually
things get corrupted and we have seen
how many of these institutions that we
have counted on relied on have but have
problems and as much as the voter rolls
same with the intelligence agencies we
need to end law enforcement I live in
Alameda there are there is by the
Sheriff's Office itself admitting how
corrupt things have become so you know
instead of trying to defend something
let's all come together unite to fix it
the problem is Allison this is for the
American people this is not about Party
politics it's very wishy-washy to insist
on coming together to fix things without
being able to demonstrate that they need
fixing and I'll give you an example
there is no evidence whatsoever that
anyone other than Joe Biden easily won
in California there is no evidence at
all that the voter rolls in California
are off there is no evidence that dead
people voted in Michigan there is no
evidence that the FBI investigation of
Mike pillow and Frank that you mentioned
is anything other than a completely
legal and well-established investigation
it's very easy to just say let's just
come together and we let's just let's
just fix it but when you're wanting to
fix things without being able able to
provide proof that they're broken it
doesn't feel like it's a good faith
position
when people are in control of what is
said to be true or not and they
themselves are the corrupt ones we don't
know
so your claims
coming from them from from people in
positions who themselves may be the ones
but they're not making claims well
you're saying I'm saying you're you're
making the claim you're making the claim
and showing no evidence about I'm sorry
you're making the claims extraordinary
claims and providing no evidence America
is shouting for truth in voting okay the
confidence of the American voter is
completely eroded
and we need to fix it we need to shore
up everyone's confidence and that's
Democrats Republic every every political
stripe Americans are Americans and we
stand here and our borders are impacted
because the world wants to come here and
live and to have the freedoms that we
possess all right and it is our duty As
Americans to make sure those freedoms
are are stand strong and we
we need to do that and not trying to
defend something we need to win if
there's no problem what's the problem
that's that's my question to you listen
let me let me ask you something else
Allison because I know you know we want
to focus on evidence you tweeted that
antifa rioters were actually the ones
breaking into the capital on January 6th
and that Maga Patriots were trying to
pull them away from going into the
building you don't honestly believe that
now do you I'm not sure I tweeted that
you did you tweeted it you tweeted it uh
January 8th 2021 we can provide the
citation
there were provocative well I mean
please send me that tweet I would love
to see it sure um I mean I tweet a lot
of things but I mean the things you
tweet
there were provocateurs there
and they were in the crowd
and they were you know Ray Epps was Oath
Keepers he's uh known to be an FBI
Associated person there is absolutely no
evidence that Ray Epps is an FBI
Associated person the night before and
that has been completely debunked
Allison it's been completely different
Allison do you mean the things you tweet
as I said I used tweets also to it to
get people to talk about subjects which
are not settled we need to clean up
America Allison do you believe that the
700 going on David would you not want it
sorted out I would not want those I was
brought to justice is there any evidence
whatsoever that you have that the 700
trumpist defendants from the capital
riots were not genuinely trumpists any
evidence
well do you have any evidence they
weren't yes their social media records
their social media histories the things
that law enforcement found in their
homes their Communications their uh
overt statements about their political
views we have we have all of that do you
have anything to suggest that none of
that is why people went
when January 6 because they questioned
the vote that's telling you that there
are many Americans who are not
comfortable with the way it went down
but my question was do you have any
evidence that they're not really
trumpists Allison hold on hold on a
second you're answering Quest different
questions do I told you why I believe
they are trumpists who went there no
they dragged out things you can put a
different frame on any evidence not a
frame not a frame hold on a second hold
on a second anybody can you can you can
paint a picture that is completely
divorced from reality by by cherry
picking evidence so is it cherry picking
to say that the rioters had exclusively
pro-trump social media history look a
grandmother is there in jail people that
just cared and they showed up and they
dragged those people before so this is
not okay this is not America those
people have a right to First Amendment
to to confront their government when
they have a question wait a second
Allison hold on a second wait a second
Allison Allison hold on a second Allison
no you first said hold on a second
Allison wait a second
nobody's going to be able to hear you
unless we can each take a turn you first
said
you don't believe they were really Mega
Trump people and now you're saying hold
on let me finish the question get in my
mouth please Don't Feed things into my
mouth
everyone out there had I don't I can't
characterize I don't know them I have
never met those 700 people
I can't tell you what they were or were
not but they were out there made the
trip
because they were concerned about the
vote so you agree that they were
trumpists
that doesn't make you a trumpist that
makes you an American
concerned about the sovereignty of your
vote almost no Democrats were concerned
about the election I'm sorry that makes
you an American
wow Allison you know you sound disc
completely disconnected from reality
right like completely certainly your
reality the empirical one for which we
have evidence no there's nothing more
empirical to yours than mine really you
have no right to to all of a sudden
stand on a high horse there's no horse
here no zebra no nothing you know
Allison when you ask me what makes me
believe something the difference Allison
is when you ask me
hold on a second but Allison wait a
second let's see if I can get a word in
edgewise Allison when you ask me why I
hold a certain belief
I give you the evidentiary reasons why
when I ask you why you hold a belief you
tell me Well we don't know or you answer
a different question you you never
provide any evidence do you see the
difference between my beliefs and yours
you're claiming evidence the evidence is
a is a p the people that showed up okay
that's evidence question that showed up
and rioted because they were mad
you know what people showed up at the
Capitol right because the president said
if you have questions you come out be an
American this was not to raid the
capital which they did though but they
did that
you know what there were infiltrators
there so the the rioters were not the
trumpists who were concerned about the
vote is that right I am not a person
that was is able to make any
determination about the people all I
know is that there were infiltrators
there that were whipping people up and
and trying to get things going wow so
Allison you're scaring me I'm scared for
the future of our nation really
genuinely and we should be that's what
that's what this is all about yeah no I
mean if folks were to vote for you I
would be very scared we should have fear
about this this is why we need to get to
the bottom of it yeah
exactly the reason is to save America
this is not Trump or anything else all
right well you've heard it here from
Allison Hayden Trump it's not about
Trump it's about America your choices in
the 14th District and the rights your
choices in the 14th District are Allison
Hayden and Eric swalwell that election
will be just weeks away Allison we're
going to be watching that race very
closely
thank you thank you very much
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
one thing that's really popular among
Republicans right now is to take
positions and support policy ideas that
are really common to parts of the world
that we often don't aspire to be like by
we I mean these very Republicans don't
and also that are playing Coy with the
ideas and policies of extreme dictators
and authoritarians and the latest idea
is that Donald Trump has been on a kick
about executing drug dealers putting
drug dealers to death Trump has now
started fundraising off of this idea he
talks about it regularly at his rallies
so let's start there here's just one
example Trump has seized on this because
I guess some in the crowd seem to kind
of like it they kill 500 people during a
lifetime and I think it's much worse
than that I think that's only what we
hear about
it would stop it I I if you didn't get
it down 75 80 90 from day one I'd be
surprised and these committees that they
set up it's laughable it's a horrible
thing we would solve that problem so
fast and I'm calling on Republicans and
Democrats immediately to Institute to
get to Washington and Institute the
death penalty for drug dealers you will
no longer have a problem there it is
kill the drug dealers and as you all
probably know by now from years of
following this guy when he seizes on
something he really seizes on it and of
course the ideal thing would be can I
make some money off of it and indeed
Donald Trump is now sending out
fundraising emails about this Donald J
trump.com sent out an email called the
death penalty and when you look inside
the email it's another one of these fake
polls and what I mean by that is it
looks like a poll they want you to take
a survey but it's actually a fundraising
pitch do you agree that drug dealers
should face the death penalty yes or no
thank you team Trump take the survey now
you know capital punishment for drug
trafficking is something that some
countries do have now it's rarely
because you got caught selling some pot
on the street but there are countries
that have extremely severe punishments
for drug dealing and drug trafficking
but I'm going to tell you what some of
those countries are
and they are typically countries that
Republicans say are backwards this is
what they say Republicans say these are
backwards countries that the U.S should
not be trying to be like these are the
countries that have the death penalty
capital punishment for drug trafficking
they include Bahrain and Bangladesh
Egypt Iran and Iraq Jordan Kuwait Libya
North Korea Qatar Pakistan Syria you get
the idea these are not exactly countries
that Republicans say should be The
Guiding Light for how the United States
should operate and the the sort of I
don't know that I want to call it funny
the sad thing to some degree is that
many of the ideas that Republicans like
are only seen in these authoritarian
type countries often Muslim
authoritarian countries you know when
right-wingers uh uh sort of art
titillated by this idea of uh Christian
nationalism a Christian version of
sharia law and a total melding of their
religion and civil government
the countries that are like that tend to
be countries Republicans don't like
right I mean it's it's Saudi Arabia it's
Iran it's you get the picture and so
when you say to Republicans the models
for what you're talking about are these
countries they well no no no those
countries are no good but here it would
be good if we did it but it's because
this is this would be with Christianity
that we would do it they're doing it
with Islam shockingly more and more
Republican ideas sound like the ideas of
these authoritarian dictatorial
countries and now Donald Trump has
seized on let's kill drug dealers and by
the way this idea of every drug dealer
kills 500 people it's absurd it's truly
absurd nobody has been able to actually
find any evidence backing that up and
now Donald Trump is trying to fundraise
off of it let's take a look at a
so-called lawyer
apparently trying to defend and
represent her client I'm gonna play some
videos for you of Donald Trump lawyer
Alina Hapa Alina Haba doesn't know
what's going on apparently because she's
going back to this old idea that the FBI
might have planted evidence at
Mar-A-Lago now I know you must be saying
David we're like weeks into this thing
we got beyond that Trump said yes he had
the documents but he Declassified them
telepathically potentially why are they
going back to the evidence might have
been planted it's because it's just a
circle of nonsense there were no
documents they were there but planted by
the FBI they were there because Trump
Declassified them and wanted them for
his Library slash Memoirs slash to read
but they weren't actually there because
the FBI planted it's just a circle it
just it's like a Mobius strip of
absurdity here is Alina Haba take a
listen to this well do you have evidence
that the FBI might have uh planted
planted something anything at Mar-A-Lago
seven weeks ago
you know what we know and I'm not going
to speak into details because because
you don't have any evidence even the
initial do you have evidence you know
what we know and I'm not going to speak
about details the answer is you have no
evidence that anything was planted it
would obviously be confidential and go
to the defense the case
um the attorney's handling it which I am
not but
as I have said on the show before
um I think the concern is that we have
recordings of these agents going in and
then we were not permitted to watch the
agents we see agents go in we see Agents
come out and we just don't know what of
what they took out was actually brought
in by them but but do you have any
evidence but no no evidence but we just
we saw them go in and we saw them come
out Mar-A-Lago go into his office space
for instance or his home his bedroom or
melania's closet and that is incredibly
concerning another thing is they came in
with equipment with bags so you never
know unfortunately the clients they
brought bags right that word politically
has led us to believe that we can't
really uh be sure that they're following
the rule of law at any point and that's
the most concerning thing I think for
all Americans right now and understand
the wishy-washy language we don't know
what they did in there we don't know
whether they're following the rule of
law do you it's same thing with the
voter fraud stuff do you have specific
evidence to suggest a belief X
rather than we've not been able to rule
X out but but do you have any evidence
of X what leads you to believe that
Trump might have actually won Georgia
well listen we just don't know who won
there's irregularities and we don't know
who won and it's always good do you have
a reason to believe that Trump
specifically got more votes than Biden
in Georgia we don't know what we're
calling for is a full investigatable but
we've an investigation has been done
it's the exact same thing here do you
have evidence we don't know what went on
the FBI brought equipment
and they weren't on camera during the
search in Trump's office ah okay asked
what Donald Trump is doing now I guess
she says Trump's handling the
investigation by playing golf uh but at
some point Elena this has got to take a
toll on just somebody's psyche uh all
these lawsuits all these jurisdictions
uh how's he doing
I I hate to burst everybody's bubble but
you know they and when I say everybody I
mean the DNC the left working uh
attackers but I can tell you I was with
him a couple days ago he is his usual
self he is in great spirits he is you
know out there working he is on the golf
course he is doing what he would
normally do the framing is like he's a
victim is he still in good spirits
despite this horrible thing that's being
done to him folks this is a guy being
investigated as a possible Criminal and
um quite honestly really optimistic for
the midterm elections and optimistic for
the country's future post Biden regime
right
um and I think that's what makes a
leader you can't get down when the
country is failing and you're under
siege you have all right so anyway you
might be wondering why would a lawyer do
this this lawyer Alina Haba who's been
increasingly uh present in media why
would why would just a lawyer take this
as a job you have to understand she's
primarily like a political actor and if
you look at her Instagram you actually
see she calls herself a patriot and a
litigator with the American flags her
pictures are with Trump her going to
Mara Lago and uh posting propaganda
about Trump posting pictures with Trump
posting a picture at one point with I'm
not even going to show it but like with
her kid her kids wearing a trump hat
this is primarily an individual acting
as a political actor not as a lawyer and
she really said I'm not one of the
people representing Trump in the legal
proceedings here she's representing
Trump on television and it's absolutely
and completely pathetic I got a
voicemail uh from an astrologist now
I don't believe in any of this stuff but
here is an astrologist explaining how
Donald Trump still has 35 approval take
a listen to this
stroller drive you know on a TV show is
similar to astrologer not an astrologist
sorry a Dragonstone that Donald uh
Trump's astrology chart uh years ago I'm
pretty accurate anyways in your video
Trump approval plunges to lowest and
year you were scared that still 30 some
percent uh approve of him yeah guess
what there's uh in astrology there's 30
degrees in each sign and 10 degrees of
them are always in what's called cusp
half of one sign half of another
and
thirty percent of the calendar is in
cost thirty percent of Trump supporters
are
Trump has three transport they're all
cusps I guarantee you they're all born
around the 20th 21st two three days in
between the 21st of the month
that's how you uh that's how 33 percent
of the people still believe in Trump
uh because astrology
serious geology charts they're fooled by
it they're they're half of one side half
of another and they're confused they're
built in Conflict that's how it works
yeah I don't believe in any of that
astrology is just not scientific even
put aside the concept of people's
personalities and lives being influenced
by the position of planets when they
were born
um most of the astrology charts aren't
even actually accurate for the time that
we were born so like at its face it
doesn't make any sense but
I always love hearing an interesting
voicemail and so I appreciate it
nonetheless even though I don't believe
in any of it we have a great bonus show
for you today we are going to talk about
hurricane Ian we're going to talk about
Edward Snowden getting Russian
citizenship from Vladimir Putin and we
will talk about the latest in the Matt
Gates investigation charges likely not
forthcoming not forthcoming oh the
bonuses or you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad all of those stories
on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpackman.com to get instant access